in this scene in universals 2020 film
The Invisible Man
Elizabeth Moss's character is thrown
across the dining room table by the
monster nailing the shot wasn't easy it
involved two stunt performers one of
whom was in a green suit various ropes
of the effects team and the precise
movements of a robotic motion controlled
camera now compare that to the original
1933 film the main character is also
invisible and while they did use some
practical effects to move objects around
for most of the movie he simply covered
in bandages the new movie couldn't rely
on just hitting strings and bandages for
a cheap scare it shakes you to the core
by using innovative effects and smart
filmmaking techniques to make the
audience terrified of something they
can't even see an upgrade to a classic
monster that is much more real and
terrifying this time around now warning
spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the
movie to see how far we've come we have
to look back to 1933 and to this man
Claude Rains
he's the actor who played the Invisible
Man in that film to create the illusion
that reigns was invisible the filmmakers
wrapped parts of him in black velvet and
filmed him in front of a black
background
this made whatever part of his body that
was supposed to be invisible seemed to
disappear
no word otherwise the rest of his
clothes appear to float in the air a
gimmicky look they tried to avoid in the
new film for the 2020 remake they
decided to make the invisible man Adrian
Griffin completely invisible making him
a more mysterious and unknown figure and
thanks to technological advances in the
decades between the two films that could
do it but Elizabeth moss and the rest of
the cast still had to have something to
react to this required a stop performer
in a green suit the stuntman would help
guide the actors and interact with them
for the fight scenes like the one in the
kitchen they use a robotic camera rig
that could be programmed to shoot each
take with the exact same timing and
movement this allowed them to capture
both the tape with the stuntman and one
clean tape without him editors could
then merge the two shots and digitally
erase him afterwards let's look at that
kitchen scene again as an example of how
this technique will work first they
would film Moss as she was about to be
thrown then they would swap her out with
a stunt
she would be attached to a rope for
support and the stunt man in the green
suit would throw her across the table
they had swap and moss again and Stitch
the three shots together
removing the stunt man and rope from the
clip removing an actor in a green suit
however was difficult to do perfectly
with so many moving parts so they also
digitally reconstructed some of the
background to make the final shot
cleaner as director Leigh Whannell said
in an interview with the big picture
podcast it's actually easier to add in a
werewolf later than it is to subtract a
stunt performer in a green suit by
rendering him completely invisible it
was up to the audience to guess where he
was without a floating hat or sunglasses
to guide them and when he made himself
known through violence it felt more like
a real person was actually there
attacking
which made the new film a much more
unsettling than the original but not
every scene required the actor in a
green suit some of the most
tension-filled moments were the
ambiguous ones when the audience doesn't
know if Adrien is there or not this
required some clever cinematography one
way they made the Invisible Man seemed
so real without using any VFX was
through frequent calculated panning
shots in most films regardless of the
genre the camera pans to a specific
character or object to focus the
audience's attention take a look at this
scene from the revenant the camera pans
to the left to show the bear approaching
cue from the woods and in the shining
while Danny is hiding in the maze we see
the camera pan to the path showing his
father limping around with an X we as
the audience have come to expect someone
or something to be in this space after
payin but the Invisible Man subvert our
expectations and pans to nothingness
just an empty space when the camera
stops Adrian should be there but he
isn't and this creates a sense of an
easiness for the viewer putting us in
the mind of Cecilia where we also feel
haunted by an invisible threat the other
key to making the cinematography scary
was to use the negative space basically
they filmed lots of empty spaces where
the characters might be even though you
can't actually see him and the audience
is never quite sure much of this was
accomplished through unusual framing
leaving extra space around or behind
Cecilia you assume he's standing in the
corner or sitting in the chair which
makes the audience uneasy for example
look at the interrogation scene the
corner of the room is
and in frame Cecilia and the audience
assume he's standing right there in the
shop listening to everything one of the
kitchen scenes is a wide still shot it
lingers there for a long time after
Cecilia leaves the frame this was
intended to be a moment for the audience
to frantically search the image for any
signs of Adrian when ale says he wanted
you to be afraid you would miss
something the director confirmed that
the Invisible Man is in most of those
shots but only he knows exactly which
ones and there are only a few where the
character is not present where we think
he might be aside from using the camera
to film negative spaces they also use it
as if it was a character of its own at
certain points in the movie the same
robotic motion controlled camera used
for the kitchen scene we mentioned
earlier have precise controlled
movements just like Adrian since the
camera represents his presence in a lot
of the movie for example in the hallway
scene at the psychiatric hospital watch
as it quickly darts back and forth and
even bins to the side you feel like
you're looking through Adrian's eyes and
he goes on his murder spree it has
quicker movements than handheld cameras
with odd jarring angles using a robotic
camera meant that actors had to get
their timing right and hit their marks
perfectly because the camera doesn't
stop it's programmed to go through a
specific set of motions at a specific
pace by combining all of these elements
play now created a believable terrifying
character that we think is on-screen but
hardly at receive without requiring any
gimmicky bandages or cliched spooky dark
sentence the Invisible Man managed to
turn a small 7 million dollar budget
into a big scare and it worked
ultimately because it's often what isn't
there that can scare you the most
[Music]